manon lambert la pâtissière claudette
lambert superviseur du maillot parisien
responsable de la cuisson marième
lacerte et aujourd'hui je suis la
goûteuse
mylène lacerte contrôle de la qualité
monique chamberlain la chef monique
chamberland et comblé la tradition se
poursuit dans sa famille si on donne
journée en famille mes filles mes
petites filles qu'il avait lu mon
clavier games serait combien d'années
que la fête sera sattler du fise
innocence ou ensemble des oeufs du sucre
du lait du beurre de la farine
un soupçon de vanille et de musc hâte
dans bien des familles canadiennes
cette recette de beignes à quelques
variantes près pouvait être puisée dans
plusieurs livres de recettes
le bug de noël on retrouve dans nos
vieux livre auquel on se réfère mais la
recette de base est toujours là mais à
peu près la mémoire site qu'on fait
encore aujourd'hui enfin mais évidemment
c'est encore le petit baigne toujours un
peu dur on donne toujours à peu près les
mêmes trucs dans mes livres anciens en
forte est auteur de livres de recettes
et propriétaire de la librairie
gourmande à explorer délivrance y est de
se ré dit à jean benoit de ma grand mère
on a tous un souvenir au soin du bien de
n'être que notre grand-mère nos
grands-parents faisait souvent qu'ils
étaient conservés donc on les faisait au
début de l'hiver ayant 1 conservait pour
jusqu'à noël
le savoir faire de grand mère se
transmettre d'une génération à l'autre
pour s'asseoir au même micro effet pivot
c'est la première fois que vous voulez
le patin mais on est bien perçu
c'est ce qu'on appelle fade et baigne
avec maman en famille g avant ma fille
nasa la belle-soeur et justement la
cuisson combien d'anglais de suda51
works le ton comme le fait vous venez me
fait rire d'abord vous avez vous déjà
essayé d'autres huiles ou c'est toujours
la même mieux que vous produire la rue
beaumont a glissé de la crise qu avec le
temps ils vont être prêtes à déguster
ça c'est vrai lors des points furent
assainies baroque g à marchaux bien sûr
également dans les traditions il y a le
bol à mélanger et l'emporte-pièce fait
combien d'années que vous cuisinez avec
symbole là même un choix en 1960
ça a toujours été le bol pour falémé
mode traditionnel si ça devait être le
bon celle ci c'est humain lebègue
c'est toujours avec le même hall
évidemment habituellement qui se passe
de mère en fille
le beigne rompt avec le trou à
l'intérieur et le truc dingue est
presque toujours pour les enfants parce
qu'on cuisine autant maintenant mais on
le garde pour les enfants alors que ça
fait partie des traditions des détails
de nos traditions mais qui sont encore
importe au bout de chacun les banques
peuvent être mangés nature au sucre à
glacer ou bien au sucre et à la cannelle
les bennes sont toujours roulée dans le
sucre en pot et donc sont blancs et une
variante au sucre le dira mais ça
c'était quand même plus rare parce que
le sucre d'érable devaient être
conservés jusqu'à noël du printemps à
noël mais c'est surtout le sucre en
poudre qu'on la bande blanche neige
c'est noël jeu quand vous vous réunissez
comme ça une fois par année longs mois
avant noël
à combien vous en fait trois quatre
soeurs baigne ça prend combien de temps
à manger après associé de famille on en
donne beaucoup à ce qu'il reste à noël
[Musique]
du moins on m'avait dit que vous étiez
là pour superviser mais que vous en
faisiez plus bas et je peux ouais je
sais pas combien d'enfants
aujourd'hui je mets en est aussi le plus
[Musique]